well let's get some definitions going
first of all I prefer to call it
conjuring because magic would be
controlling nature by means of spells
and incantations and I tried spells and
intent Asians they don't work you got to
use tricks you see so conjuring is
approximating the effect of what would
be a genuine magic miracle or some kind
so with that definition in mind I got
interested in magic I was one of those
unfortunate kids so it was a child
prodigy and believe me that is an
unfortunate circumstance I had a very
unhappy time of it when I was born and
raised in Toronto Canada and I stayed
out of public school because I didn't
meet it I was South educated and so I
took a trip to the casino theatre on
Queen Street in Toronto Canada many many
years ago just a little guy was so big I
guess I was about 12 or so at the time
and I saw a magician oh man that got my
attention I figured maybe that's
something I could know something more
about up until then I was going to be a
chemist or an archaeologist one of the
other I didn't know but archaeology and
chemistry lost me to the art of
conjuring and I maybe took it up and
learned a few things and Here I am
well the the magician I saw at that
theater that wednesday afternoon matinee
was Harry Blackstone senior brother
short gentleman dressed in tails with
bushy white hair and a bit of a lisp he
spoke like this more or less and he was
wonderful he was a giant he was a he was
a well either a demon or an angel I
wasn't quite sure but he could do
wonderful things so that really got my
attention and from then on I said to
meet the other people in the in the
business all the way up to Blackstone
there Jr who was his son and took over
the the trade after his father died and
both of them are now deceased
unfortunately and I missed both of them